hey we're rhett and Link we're here at
BuzzFeed today we're gonna be answering
some questions about our first time I'll
open it for you make it easier okay
first aim or AOL account name I remember
I had one that had it was all consonants
r h TT MC g h ln you could have said
that faster
my first AOL user name was leaky faucet
with like three numbers at lincoln
faucet leaky faucet was a missed
opportunity now I know the answer to the
question if you could go back in time
and change anything what would it be it
would be my AL user name to make it more
punny next question first big purchases
have YouTube
so we uploaded a video to YouTube in
2006 when YouTube started and then I
probably went out in boxing I don't know
some saltiness you're forgetting we
bought a Scion together hmm
and we went in on a Scion we went to the
bank we got all the cash we had because
everybody told us you need to buy in
cash we didn't know that that meant that
you've you just pay for paid in full we
literally bought up an envelope full of
$18,000 which i think is technically
over you want to carry around I was
gonna follow it up at the bank teller
and say well can I have it all in once
and can I get a briefcase
and it still probably wouldn't have been
enough to justify briefcase what is it
like a lunch sack yeah we're going to do
first thing you do when you wake up roll
over pick up my phone and build my
self-image from the YouTube comments
first thing I do when I wake up is roll
over see if Rhett's texted me because
his self-image is being shattered by
YouTube comments yep every day
first time being recognized in public
still kind of still kind of hoping for
that
we're kind of looking around I
frequently go up to people or in the
mind so me my face ring any bells
YouTube much I remember a time I was out
with my family and we ran into my
grandmother is that didn't expect to see
you guys here but she knew it was you
she recognized us right off the bat oh
the whole family all of us and the last
one first pay my first pet was a dog
named Tucker he was brown and shaggy
remember the day he died yeah we
performed a funeral for him we buried
him in a refrigerator box because he was
huge rained a lot the next day and the
whole grape filled with mud and I've
jumped into it we jumped into it my
first pet was pokey a hamster that got
lost for a month and we found him inside
of a sleeping bag in my closet and he
had been living off of the fibers we've
been eating the sleeping man yeah you
look for another year we're rhett and
Link we enjoyed answering questions
about our first time please check out
our so good mythical morning every
weekday on YouTube
[Music]